All right.
So last time
we started to study in perfect competition,
we looked at the Cornell model,
but the bigger theme,
yeah.
The bigger theme is the study of how firms compete outside of this.
Not An easy cases that you study in one 15 to outside of the example of
monopoly,
whether it's anyone from until there's not much competition.
And I decided the case of perfect competition where there are so many firms,
it's as if each firm is a price taker.
All right,
I'm going to go,
we're going to continue with that today and in fact you're going to continue
with it on into the homework.
So last time we looked at Corno,
that was the model we started with.
Yeah.
Two firms competing in quantities and just to review in a bit what we did last
time,
uh,
the kind of exercise that,
so I think is this right?
I think I probably went a little fast last time I was kicking myself afterwards.
How did I get,
people can nod or shake their heads with it.
I think I went a bit fast so I'm so,
I'm sorry if that,
but if though if there was a time to go too fast,
it was probably last time because it turns out this is something that's covered
very well in the textbook so it's covered in chapter six of the textbook,
but the kind of exercise we did last time is a useful exercise.
But those of you who are econ majors,
the way we sold that Cornell model was we did three kinds of things.
We did something very nerdy,
namely we just play with calculus and Algebra.
All right?
That was one mathy.
We did something a little bit less nerdy.
That is,
we drew some pictures that represented what we'd found and we did a third thing
which was we tried to match this up to the economic intuition about monopoly and
ah,
perfect competition and demand curves and so on.
And this exercise of being able to work in these three different modes,
economic intuition,
graphs and kind of nerdy high school math is a lot of what we want to get you
used to as economic majors.
It's just got a trunk.
Say easily between those.
We're going to Apollo's.
We're going too fast,
but it's still a useful exercise I think so.
I have looked at it in the book now back to the lessons in a way from the
nerdiness or second,
what are we learn what at the end of the day we learned that in the corner of
equilibrium things where as we perhaps we might have anticipated things.
W W sat naturally between the extreme cases,
so the amount of output produced by the industry was somewhere between the case
that would be on the monopoly and on a perfect competition.
It was more than under monopoly,
less than perfect competition prices in the industry.
If we'd gone back and checked which set between,
they would be lower than the monopoly prices,
but higher than the perfect competitive prices.
Industry profits would be inbetween.
Interesting.
Rockets would be less than monopoly.
They must've just been monopolies and so that's the highest they could ever be
and the higher than perfect competition,
which of course has zero profits in this case.
All right,
and consumer surplus,
the benefits flowing into consumers.
My in between.
So in fact,
the model in addition to this or notice of the model,
it ended up with a result we kind of believe in.
You have imperfect competition.
It's somewhere between perfect competition and no competition.
If Fox,
what's the bus?
The buses that there are other ways we could model imperfect competition.
And as we're going to see today,
they yield different offices.
So the first thing we're going to do today is look at a different form of
competition,
which is called Bertrand Competition.
It's a corner one is competing in quantities.
Yeah.
And Bertrams is competing
in prices.
All right.
And just a quick check.
And this is not for the camera.
How many of you have seen better on competition before?
So good.
Many of you.
So there's gonna be reviews still.
Again,
for those of you who it isn't for whom,
which isn't review.
Don't worry.
We'll do this Rosalie quickly.
But I hope I won't rush it like I did last time.
There's any consolation I get when I feel I've rushed Alexia.
I have a sleepless night.
So if you had to sleep at night because you're worried about it.
I think I'm having a sleepless night too about that.
Alright,
so there's two firms just as there was before and just as there was before,
the flux of the players are those two firms and just as there was last time,
they're producing an identical products.
Yeah.
All right,
so the products we mentioned last time,
what coke and Pepsi,
how about you could think of other products that are pretty much identical.
All right,
and just as last time,
we're going to assume that costs a constant marginal costs.
Well,
as soon as that comes at marginal cost,
I said it was last time because he put a c just to remind those people who are
not economics majors,
what that means.
It means if I produce one unit,
then it costs me see to produce a re tune it.
It cost me to see a hundred units,
100 seniors.
So all right.
Now what's different here from from last time,
and I've already told you,
but I'll repeat it this time.
However,
instead of sitting quantities instead of just deciding how much coke and Pepsi
to produce and spewing it out from the market and getting prices take care of
themselves this time,
the firms are going to set prices and let quantities take care of themselves.
All right,
so the,
the the strategy set this time up prices
and again,
so don't get confused.
Now normally we use [inaudible] for strategy but let's use p since that prices.
So they're going to be p one will be the price of good one of m one and p two
will be the price of fun too.
And the strategy set formerly,
let's just simplify here.
Let's assume that for each firm I they can set their price,
anything bigger than zero and anything less than one just to keep life simple.
All right,
so this is a little bit more realistic,
perhaps perhaps more or less stick to think of firms actually thinking about
what prices to set and then adjusting the quantities they actually ship based on
demand.
All right.
It depends on,
I don't mean to radars about that cause that you could imagine the other way
round.
But this,
you know,
you talk to managers,
it sounds more realistic at least.
But retail goods like coke and Pepsi,
all right?
So we know how prices are set.
They're set by the firms.
So the next question is,
where do the quantities come from?
All right,
so how did,
where did the corners these come from?
And they're going to come from demand.
And let me use a big queue of p,
a big queue of p two B.
The total quantity produced the total quantity demanded in the market.
So this will be the total quantity of,
uh,
of goods produced by good goods produced by foam one and goods produced by,
from too,
that are consumed.
All right?
This is the total quantity of coke plus Pepsi.
And we're going to,
and I noticed there's no subscript on this p and you'll see why in a second.
So we'll assume is to make life simple that the total quantity produced is one
minus p.
And I'll say this and then write it more carefully,
where p is the lower of the two prices.
All right?
So the total quantity demanded is one minus p what p is the lower of the two
prices.
All right?
Now to make that lower,
the two prices comment a little bit more rigorous.
Let's figure out what the demand actually is for these firms to what's going on
here.
So let's look at the demand for from one.
All right,
we're just going to end up being the quantity that they sell.
So that's going to be Q one and watch that going to be,
well,
it's going to be one minus p one if they're the low price firm.
So if p one is less than PC,
right?
So if they're the low price from if coke is the low price from only coke sells
in the market,
there's no Pepsi in the market,
uh,
and one minus p one quantity of coke is sold,
it's going to be a zero.
If p one is bigger than pizza,
all right?
So of Pepsi as though is the low price a drink in the market,
then no coke is sold at all and it's going to be one minus p one over to in the
case.
Well,
coke and Pepsi cost exactly the same.
All right?
You should be ready to be realizing this is not exactly a realistic,
right?
We're making a lot of very strong assumptions here,
but nevertheless,
it's going to be instructive to look at this model.
All right?
So I've got the firms,
they the players,
I don't what their strategies are.
I know a little about the structure of the market.
I still need to tell you what payoffs are
and just as last time,
the firms are going to try and maximize profits.
All right?
So what's the profit for from one going to be,
and I write it separately for firms to,
it's going to be the quantity itselves
times the price.
It gets for that quantity minus that quantity at sales times the cost it costs
incurred in producing that quantity.
So again,
it's for from one,
it's the quantity itselves times the price.
This is it's revenue.
Yeah,
minus the quantity itselves times.
See the cost.
This is cost.
All right?
I can rewrite that a little bit more simply as Q one brackets,
p one minus C.
Alright.
Y Q one where this Q1 let's,
but let's keep it in square brackets.
This Q one is this object here?
Why does everyone understand what's going on?
I mean,
the Algebra doesn't really help the intuition here.
The attrition is pretty straightforward.
Coke and Pepsi are producing this stuff.
They're setting prices.
If Pepsi is the low price than coke sells nothing.
If,
if coke is the low price it sells.
This amount at its profits are basically given by this equation.
It's basically just revenues minus costs.
All right,
so we have,
what we want to do is we want to figure out what the Nash Equilibrium looks like
in this market and just just before we go any further,
no,
just that really this is the same basic market we looked at before,
right?
Both caught times has a demand curve out there in one model with thought of the
firms that in quantities and the market determining prices,
and here we have the firms in prices in the market to sell in quantities,
but the basic underlying economic structure of this is very,
very similar.
All right?
All right,
so you find the Nash Equilibrium.
We're going to have to find best responses.
All right?
It's what we're gonna do together,
uh,
is to figure out what these best responses look like.
And uh,
let's try and do that.
I want to figure out the best response or from one
as a function of the price chosen by,
from to the best price for from one to choose.
Given that from two is choosing P two.
And I want to do this carefully and slowly.
And before I even start,
let me point out in passing that calculus is not going to help us here.
All right?
So for those of you who are nerdy enough to understand the next sentence,
let me just say it.
This is a discontinuous,
this is a discontinuous,
a payoff function.
So differentiating isn't going to get you very far,
right?
For this before people whom that didn't mean anything.
It doesn't matter.
We're not going to use calendars today.
All right?
Okay.
So there are different cases to about.
So one case to think about is what if the other from your coke,
what if Pepsi is pricing below cost?
What if Pepsi is pricing below cost?
And your coke,
what should you price as if you're trying to maximize your profits?
Let me try and wave their hands on the APP and know the answer perhaps is
pricing below costs?
What's your best response?
Yeah,
there's a guy on there.
Do you want to shout out?
Just get out of the market because it's not worth it for you to sell anything,
right?
So the so,
so I've forgotten your name.
I should know it by now.
Your,
your name is Sudipta to dip to says get out of the markets,
right?
If the,
if the other guy is pricing below costs,
you didn't want to start on a thing.
That's the right intuition.
How in this game do I quote,
get out of the market and you have to write and I asked you right,
I don't,
I don't want to be involved in this market.
If the other guy is selling below cost,
how do I,
how do I operationalize that in this game?
How do I actually,
how do I actually manage hourly?
There's somebody here,
just,
just wait for the mic a second and I'll shout it out.
You did set your price above his price,
the answer was set your price above his price.
So the other guy is pricing below cost.
The way which I avoid making losses is to set my price above his price.
Ryan Assistant,
make sure we understand this.
If the other guy is selling below cost,
the only way I can make any sales is the price below his price.
I will then make sales.
But each of those sales I'm making a loss on.
I don't want to make losses.
So I just quote,
get out of the market.
And the way I quote get out of the market is by pricing above the other guy.
I don't ever understand that.
All right.
Okay,
so now more interestingly,
we leave a little gap here.
What if the other guy is pricing above costs?
What do I want to do with the other guys?
Pricing above costs.
Taking it that guy with the beard here,
shout it out.
Cause we have that.
Mike has new,
you set a price below his butt above,
above or equal to cost.
All right,
so,
so if the other guy is pricing above costs,
I want to set prices below his to the ice,
steal the whole of the markets and make profits on those sales.
So where is to suppose his pricing it and we set the prices of Windsor in one.
Suppose he's pricing at a at a point.
Aids all be a good price for me to set
same same Gaia
as a small amount below his prices.
You can do a small amount as a small amount below his price as I can.
It's more of a blow his price as I can.
So basically I'm going to do here is I'm going to set my price to equal his
price minus a little bit and I'll use the level epsilon to mean just a little
bit.
I'll just undercut him a little bit by just undercutting the middle bits.
I'm going to get the whole of the markets and I'll make as much money as I can
on those sales.
Now that's almost right.
That's almost right.
That's kind of 90% of rights,
but it's not quite right.
I need to be a little bit careful.
Now,
why do I need to be a little careful here?
So this is almost right,
but it's not quite right.
You have the same same guy
you want your price to be at or above cost.
Oh,
that's okay.
That's certainly true.
Okay,
so that's true.
So I said fair enough.
So I want to,
I want to make sure this epsilon is not so big as it pushes me below cost.
That's certainly true that that's,
that's correct.
There's another little issue here.
So here's the other issue.
There's a price in this market we might want to think of as the kind of focal
price.
There's an interesting price and that's the price at which the price I would
choose.
We're either monopolist,
I suppose the other guy didn't exist who's Pepsi didn't exist.
The coke has the whole market.
Right?
Then we sold out this problem.
We would solve out what the monopoly prices.
That's an exercise you didn't want.
15 all right.
And notice that if Pepsi has priced above the monopoly price,
I suppose suppose Pepsi is priced this good so high that it's above the monopoly
price.
Then as the gentleman said,
I can capture the whole locket by pricing just below Pepsi.
However,
however,
then I then I have the whole market.
I just didn't find the monopolists but suddenly I'm pricing above them and
operate price might can't be right.
Right.
I never want to price above the monopoly price cause I know that the monopoly
price where I'm the monopolist is the most profit I could ever make.
Is that right?
All right.
Do you need to be a little bit careful?
This also that says I just undercut Pepsi.
That's true.
Provided provided that Pepsi hasn't gone above the monopoly price.
Right.
If he's going above it,
if he's got above the monopoly price,
we need to be a little bit more careful.
If pizza is actually above the monopoly price,
then what's my best response in that case?
I'll do my best homes in that case.
Yeah.
Can we get Katie who's in green there
pricing at the monopoly pricing of the monopoly price.
So if Pepsi is dumb enough to price above monopoly,
sure I will undercut Pepsi,
but I won't upset undercoat Pepsi by a penny all on the cup.
Pepsi all the way down to the monopoly price and make monopoly profits.
I'll be very happy.
I'd be wondering what on earth is perhaps the up to,
but that's fine.
All right,
so here my best response is to price at the monopoly price.
All right.
And there's one other possibility here I've missed,
which is what if Pepsi prices at marginal cost itself,
this is the one missing case here.
What if Pepsi prices at marginal cost?
What's my best response?
In this case?
Pepsi's pricing.
Exactly.
At marginal cost.
What's my best response?
Uh,
yeah.
wait for the mic.
This,
this is Henry.
I think shout out to price at marginal cost as well.
I could price at a marginal cost as well.
How much profit do I make if I,
if I price it,
medical cost as well.
Zero profits,
I make zero profits.
So that certainly is a best response by saying at marginal cost as well.
What else would be a best response?
That's,
that's correct.
But what else would be a best response
price above that?
All right.
It doesn't really matter as long as I do price below weights.
As long as they are priced below it,
I'm not gonna make any money anyway,
right?
If I price below it,
I'm going to lose money.
All right,
so this best response actually is a pretty complicated object and we could,
if we're going to go like we did last time,
we could take the time to draw this thing,
but it's a bit of a mess,
so I won't worry about doing that right now.
All right,
so the best response is actually pretty complicated,
even though the press response is pretty complicated.
And by the way,
obviously the things,
that's a metric for player too,
even though these best responses are pretty complicated,
it turns out that there's only one nash equilibrium in this game.
Watch the Nash Equilibrium.
Somebody watched the but what rate?
Raise your hand high.
All you guys,
it was a huge number of hands.
They said they'd seen it before.
So,
uh,
who saw this model before?
So fewer hands go up where they know there's a question coming,
right?
There's a different incentive.
All right.
Who remembers what the Nash Equilibrium is?
Yeah,
there's a guy tied that guy right by you.
They're at sea shout back even I caught her,
you see at to see,
okay,
so the,
the Nash equilibrium here,
the Nash equilibrium is for both firms to set their prices equal to marginal
cost
and you can check that both firms are then playing a best response.
So that's,
that's all right if it,
if m two is,
is charting a c,
then a best response for from one is to set up just with the ones that hit is to
set a price.
He put a marginal costs.
And if um,
uh,
one is it the pricing at marginal costs,
then conversely,
a best response for from to is to price it marginal cost.
All right?
Slightly harder exercise is to check that nothing else is in actually whenever
am what else?
Think about that a second.
Suppose from one is pricing,
uh,
at marginal cost and from two a is pricing at something higher?
Uh,
at um,
uh,
a c plus?
Uh,
I dunno.
Three apps.
One a little bit higher.
Yeah.
All right.
Suppose foam one is pricing at marginal cost and from to and from a two is
pricing at c pass three epsilon.
Is this an actually collaborate?
I just think about from two.
First of all,
it's from to playing a best response to foam one.
It's from to playing at restaurants to found one.
So I claim it is right.
What does this check Kathleen from?
One is to PR is pricing at marginal costs,
right?
The best respondents if the other guys pricing at marginal costs is to price at
marginal costs or above.
And this is marginal cost or above.
So this is the best response.
So from two is playing a bass response.
This is the best response for from two given that he won.
Is it?
See what's the problem here?
Why is it nevertheless,
I claimed that he's not an actual equilibrium.
Why is it not a Nash Equilibrium?
Who has an incentive to deviate.
Take him to get the guy way at the back way,
way,
way in the back by the door.
Go ahead.
Shout out from ones,
get along and produce at c plus to epsilon.
Exactly.
This is not a best response.
This is not
the best response.
And the reason is that the best response for from one if from two is charging c
plus three little bits is to try it is to price it c plus two the guys.
Thank you.
All right,
so it turns out it's pretty easy to check that this is the only nash equilibrium
in the game.
All right.
Now what's the lesson?
What a draw from this?
Well,
as an exercise in game through that really wasn't very hard.
All right?
As an exercise in finding nash equilibrium by this stage.
And of course most of you are looking at that saying,
yeah,
that wasn't hard.
So what's the point here?
The point is that in this game in which firms competed in prices,
even though there were only two firms in the market,
right?
Only one from more than monopoly.
Right?
We get a dramatically different result than we had last time.
In particular,
we find that prices in the market are equal to marginal costs.
We find that profits and equilibrium is equal to
zero and we find this lots of consumer surplus cause prices really as low as
they ever could be.
In fact,
the outcome here,
this equilibrium here is for all intents and purposes,
the same equilibrium we would have had had the bean thousands of firms in the
market and had this been a perfectly competitive market.
All right,
so even though there's only two firms here with price competition,
identical products,
we end up with an outcome that looks exactly like perfect competition accepted
the for the fact that only two phones,
that's the outcome.
It's like
perfect competition
even though
it's only two.
Fuck.
That's a pretty surprising results.
It would suggest.
Think about this as a policy things.
If you believe this model,
do you think that has really an accurate model of,
of society and you're a regulator working in the Department of Justice or you're
a judge trying to judge some monopoly case or you're a commissioner on the
European Court or whatever.
Trying to judge some compassion and competition case.
All you'd worry about is getting one competitor in each market to firms in each
market and you'd be done,
right?
You wouldn't worry about entry beyond two.
All right.
Now my guess is we don't believe that.
We don't believe that.
All right,
we'll come back to that in a second,
but they make a different amount.
If we get that,
not me doing that.
Let me move this down.
All right.
Still doing it.
Okay.
That's probably the wire.
Sorry.
Hi.
Let me just remove it and I'll shout.
Okay.
I'm going to shout now.
Can People still hell banks?
Can people still hear me?
Yup.
Okay,
thank you.
All right.
Uh,
so I have to turn down the other mic a bit.
All right,
so what's another thing to remark here is even though we looked at essentially
the same market as we looked at last time and we didn't make it and he's really
significant change,
we just say instead of thinking of them pricing study in quantities,
think of them saying prices have been here.
Just thought experiments.
We ended up with a radically different outcome.
All right,
so another lesson here is the same,
assessing
the same assessing as lost time as core.
No,
but with
a different
strategy set,
I definitely thinking about what they're doing
led to a very different outcome
and that's worrying,
right?
It's worrying because you can't go away feeling comfortable out this.
You can't think that it really could make so much difference in the real world.
How prices and quantities is welfare and profit is going to work out depending
on some thought experiment about how I think about my strategy set.
All right,
so there's little worry going in about not just this example but about the
course,
about the whole theme of Learning Game Theory.
All right,
so what's going to save us here?
What's going to save us is if we inject a little bit more reality back in the
model,
we're going to get back and more sensible results.
So what we're going to do now is we're going to relax some of the assumptions of
this batch Ron model,
and it's going to do two things for us.
First,
it's going to give us an outcome that we believe the outcome we believe,
I think is that imperfect competition should look something between monopoly and
perfect competition.
It shouldn't look like better competition.
I think most of us don't believe the two firms is enough to make a perfect
competition that the regulator shouldn't worry about the third farm.
All right,
I'm the second thing that's going to do from a more theoretical point of view is
it's going to suggest to us that actually actually things aren't quite as bad as
we thought.
In fact,
if we modeled this more carefully,
we'll get roughly the same prediction.
Uh,
either way.
All right,
so what's the assumption we're going to change?
Well,
before I say that,
I just say I'm not going to change it.
You are all right.
So rather than go through this again,
that whole third time I've gone through it once and quantities and once in
prices.
I'm going to get you guys to do it this time by having you do it on a homework
assignment.
Well why?
Well partly because I think it's a good exercise but also I didn't want this
class to be a class where you sit there,
you know with your cup of well of his coffee.
Uh,
if needed to keep awake and you watch me solve models cause that's not how you
learn what I want this to pass to be as a class where it is sometimes like in
this homework assignment you take,
you know,
I set up a model for you,
what sort of sets up the story for you and then you have to actually figure out
how do I set this up properly and how do I solve it out?
Because at the end of the day,
if game three is going to be useful for you in your later lives,
whether it's in dating or in running a company or whatever happens to be,
you need to be able to go from the story to the model.
All right.
Having said that,
I'll tell you what the homework assignments going to be about.
The assumption we're going to change is the idea that products are identical.
So we're gonna look at a case
when you say you board.
Well,
products are differentiated.
Okay.
Hello?
I'm going to claim that assuming that products are not identical is a pretty
safe assumption for most of the world.
Well,
most things are going to see in the world.
So we're going to look at what are called differentiated.
Okay?
Differentiated products,
and in particular,
we're going to get a particular version of this,
but we're going to call the linear Stacy
model.
All right?
So what do we mean by products being differentiated?
So I started off with an example that's pretty bad for this story,
namely coke and Pepsi.
And I'll be honest,
how many of you in a blind taste test can taste the difference between ordinary
coke and ordinary Pepsi?
Oh,
quite a few.
Okay,
that's good for my case,
right?
It's a number of,
you think those are different products,
right?
So number of you,
even if the price was just a tiny bit different,
might have a preference for one rather than the other.
So without getting in trouble by putting the camera on you,
how many of you have would have a profit if the prices were essentially the
same?
How many of you would have a strip preference of a Pepsi and how many of those
strict preference for coke?
And how many of you have a strip preference for diet?
A diet coke?
That's amazing.
I stopped.
I don't in mind.
Okay,
I'll get with that.
But you're making my point.
The point I'm trying to make case products and not identical.
Alright.
Products are not identical.
Okay?
For the most part,
there's a little bit of difference between products and that's actually gonna
work.
If we inject that a little bit of realism into the world,
it's actually going to help us.
So what we would like,
what would we'd like?
We'd like a model in which firms set prices,
because for the most part we think firms do set prices.
Not Quantity is not always,
but for the most part,
but we'd like a modal that yields the yields and outcome that looks that when
you only have two firms look somewhere between monopoly and perfect competition.
So we'd make an outcome that looks a little bit like core.
No,
but we'd like the strategy set to be prices.
And this is going to do,
the trick is going to tell up to do the trick as you'll find out in your
homework assignments.
So how are we going to model this on the homework?
The way we're going to model differentiated products is to imagine,
just to take a simple example,
imagine a city and this city has one long straight road through it.
So this study is not a city in New England.
It's a city in the Midwest where everything's flat and the roads just go
completely straight.
All right,
you can think of as being,
I know a mile long,
does it really matter?
All right,
let's just think of it as being a mile long.
And we're going to assume that consumers are evenly spread along this city.
All right?
Let's do it was evenly spread along the city.
So there's basically consumers everywhere.
They evenly distributed.
And we're going to assume that one of these firms,
one of these firms that's call it from one
yeah,
sits at 0.0 and the other firm
I'm to sits at 0.1.
Now this is what we're gonna do in the homework assignment,
but I'm just make it make the arguments that you could also imagine firms
sitting think somewhere between zero and one,
right?
You're going,
wait,
we could do a more general jog if we wanted to,
but for now it's just assume that one of these firms has its shop at one end of
the town and the other one has it shot at,
uh,
at the other end of the town.
All right?
So let's think about a particular consumer.
Just oppose this consumer is here.
Point.
Why is it all right?
So notice that this consumer is a distance.
Why Hawaii from from one sort of if if she consumes from from one,
she has to walk a distance of why.
All right.
And she's a distance of one minus y from foam to,
is that right?
So if she from from to she has to walk,
she has to walk one minus y.
All right.
That's going to turn out to be key in our model as we'll see in a second.
All right,
so firms as before,
I'll going to set prices
and I won't write everything down because it's all written down on the homework
assignment,
which is already on the web.
But in fact firms are going to maximize profits aimed to maximize profits.
Firms are going to have constant marginal costs,
will make one other assumption to keep life simple.
We'll assume that each consumer buys one and only one product.
Each consumer's going to buy one product either from,
from one or from from two.
Alright,
so the issue is going to be which foam does each consumer go and buy that
product from?
Which department does each consumer choose and what?
Assume
but each consumer
chooses the products.
Okay,
who's,
I'll be careful here.
Who is total
cost to,
Huh?
It's smaller I why don't we may total costs.
What does that look for the,
for the consumer at point y for the front zone poll
for example,
for the consumer at point y if they buy from from one,
if they buy from from one,
then they pay the price p one which is set by from one,
but they also have to pay a transport cost.
The cost of them of having to walk all the way there and walk all the way back.
All right,
and we'll,
we'll give a name tag I transport cost.
Well say it t y squared.
All right,
so why,
why is the distance they have to travel?
Right?
And t why it's good is that transport costs.
So this object here we could think of as a transport cost,
right?
If the same consumer buys from from to she pays p two plus t times again the
distance squared.
So that's going to be one minus y squared.
And once again,
this last term is a transport cost.
All right?
I know just that these transport costs go up in the,
in the distance you have to travel and they go out pretty fast.
They'd go up,
uh,
at,
at rate square.
All right?
So what you're going to do on the homework assignments is sold out this market.
You're gonna assume that firms set prices to maximize profits.
You're going to know what firms costs are,
you're going to work out what firms do demands are going to look like for each
possible prices they could set.
And you're going to solve out the whole nash equilibrium.
And then we're going to look at that Nash equilibrium and you're gonna Think,
uh,
how does that compare to what I saw in the corner case and so on.
All right?
So that's on the homework assignments.
Yeah,
but before I leave this,
let me just point out that this is a little bit more general than it might
appear.
So here I've treated what makes products difference as being,
uh,
where the,
where the shops are located.
All right?
So here I've interpreted these terms here as transport costs and I've
interpreted what makes the products difference is the fact that one of them is
selling at one end of the town and the other one is selling at there at the,
at the,
at the right hand,
end of town.
All right?
But actually we could consider this model more generally.
Let's just do so briefly here.
Let me just redraw the town.
Here's my town again.
All right,
I don't have to regard this,
this products,
uh,
this,
this line as being distance along the high street of the town.
It could be something else about the products.
So for example,
and whatever it is you guys imagine makes coke and Pepsi different.
It could be that thing and went what that is,
but whatever that,
whatever that is.
Let me take an example though.
I understand better Landis and coke and Pepsi.
So imagine we're talking about beer.
All right?
I think about beer.
This is the BMR kit,
alright,
this distance here could be something like the alcohol content of the flavor of
the beer.
All right?
And you can imagine different products.
Therefore that are on the market positioning themselves or being positions at
different points on the line.
So for example,
you know up here everyone else,
beer flavor,
this might be Guinness.
All right,
this might be good actually I can't even spell,
but you know what I mean.
All right.
And if you think about the drinks industry more generally here rather than just
beer,
this would be Guinness.
This would be a Poland spring.
All right,
this is water,
right?
And everything else would be in between here.
All right?
So if we just go a tiny distance in here,
all right,
this is a bud light,
right?
And so on.
Right?
Right.
And you,
you,
you could put everything on this line.
All right.
I think that maybe I'm not really allowed to do this on this model.
The only a counter is the part of the truth is that Bud light might be down here
somewhere,
but I'm not allowed to do that.
Alright.
So,
leaving aside that specific example of beer,
you think about some product that has some dimension on which it varies and we
can use this model,
we can use this model to see how competition is going to work in that market.
But now notice that this transport costs is going to be a different
interpretation.
Now instead of being the cost of traveling that distance to go and buy the
product,
what's it going to be?
It's going to be that.
If my,
if my preferred bear flavor is here,
say,
Hey,
this is me,
my preferred bear flavors here,
then if I end up having to consume Guinness,
I have to pay the price of gas and I also incur some costs because Guinness
isn't the perfect beer for me.
It's a little bit too strong.
All right.
And if I consume a bud light,
then I have to pay for the bud lights.
I think typically costs less than the price.
It was a rural price is less than Guinness,
but I also pay an additional cost from the fact that the got bud light when I
drink it.
Um,
uh,
causes me to see,
tell us we've heard that put likely like that.
Alright.
So basically that transport cost is now the,
the,
the lack of pleasure I caused by drinking a product that isn't perfect for me.
All right.
Does everyone understand the story here?
All right,
so you're going to figure out what happens with this story very generally,
even in the particular case actually,
uh,
on the homework assignment.
But I want you to understand that there's this much more general story
underlying this and this is a pretty good model of how a have a lot of markets
as a kind of model that you'd see again if you went on to graduate school.
Yeah.
Alright.
Now I want to spend the rest of today doing something quite different,
but you'll see it isn't all that different.
I'm going to go away from starting imperfect competition and go back and visit
something we studied almost the first day or maybe the second day.
And that's elections.
I want to go back to elections.
And why do I want to go back at this point?
Well,
one reason I want to go back is you'll notice I've been putting up these lions
on the board and when we visited elections that uh,
on the second day we said that you can think of that line on the board as being
not just um,
not just uh,
left wing right wing politics but also some dimension of of products.
So I want to go back again now we're considering the line on the board as being
flavor in beer.
Yeah.
Well location in a town and I want to go back to politics now and go back to the
interpretation we started with so that left and right will end up being left
wing politics versus right wing politics.
All right.
I'm going to take the same basic idea back to the politics model.
Yeah.
And we'll spend the rest of today in politics.
So we're going to be doing political science or political science as it means
game theory for the rest of the day.
Yeah.
We're going to study something called the candidate
voter model
candidate voter model.
All right.
This model is going to look a lot like the models we looked at already a few
weeks ago
in particular has I advertised?
There will be a line and this line will go from a zero to one and the left hand
side of this line will represent the left wing and the right hand side of the
line will represent the right wing.
So that's the same as before and as before.
As in the downs or hoteling model we discussed already a few weeks ago,
we're going to assume that voters are evenly spread along the line.
All right,
so we're going to assume even distribution.
Yeah,
all voters on the light.
I'm also going to assume just as we did last time,
that voters are going to vote for the closest candidate.
Okay.
Suppose just vote for the closest
candidate.
So all of these assumptions are the same assumptions we started two weeks ago or
two and a half weeks ago,
and which you actually started in your first homework assignment.
Is that right?
But I want to go back there because I want to do now is I want to change some
critical assumptions of that model and see that by making those,
making those changes,
we're going to get some very different outcomes.
So in particular,
the new things here,
two things,
water,
the number of candidates,
the number of candidates is not,
is not fixed.
So the number of candidates in this model is going to be indigenous.
All right?
Previously we looked at models where there were two candidates are on your
homework assignment,
three candidates.
Now we're going to allow the number of candidates to adjust itself.
And the second assumption we're going to make,
which is new,
is that we're going to assume that candidates cannot choose that position.
All right?
So the idea is any candidate who spans and it's election,
you know who that candidate is,
you know whether their right wing or left wing.
So they can't tell you there's something else,
right?
So candidates
can not choose
that position.
All right?
So this is a,
this is a simple thing,
right?
Because you think about the current election,
there's a debate about whether Hillary Clinton,
for example,
can choose right now to be at the center of the Democratic Party,
given her past history of votes.
For example,
on the Iraq war or on the other side.
There's a debate about whether Mitt Romney can choose to be,
I guess he's trying to choose himself to be on the right hand wing of the
Republican Party,
given he has a record of government as being governor of Massachusetts,
when Provo,
when he provided state health care,
for example.
All right,
so it's quite difficult in the real world for candidates to position themselves,
voters tend to know that those candidates have track records.
That's something we mentioned already three weeks ago,
two weeks ago.
We're going to take that fixed now.
We're gonna assume you know who these candidates are.
All right,
so what are we actually going to assume?
We're going to assume that each voter in the model is a potential candidate.
So this is the thinking,
nice idealized version of American politics.
Each of you who is above 18 and is an American citizen and was born in America
and maybe have your mom,
you've got to be more than Bobby tier,
above whatever it is,
whatever the rule is,
whatever the constitution says,
each of you can potentially stand up now and say you're going to run for
president,
right?
I'm guessing all of you are ruled out by age actually.
Oh,
this is not the same rule in the constitution,
but of them.
I just pretend that's not there.
All right,
so the idea of the model is each vota
is,
hey,
potential
a potential candidate.
All right.
That's a very appealing assumption,
I think in a democracy.
So what I want to do is I want to lay this out a little bit more formally as a
game,
and then since we haven't done anything like this for a week or so,
we're going to play the game.
All right?
So you're about to play this game.
So pay attention,
please.
All right,
so who are the voters?
Who are the players?
The players are the voters,
right?
The voters or candidates would have you want to call them
candidates.
Can the greats,
I knew one day
in this game they're going to be you.
And the key strategy here,
essentially the Australia is,
can be very simple.
The strategy is do you run or not?
The reason that's going to be the strategy is that voting is not going to be
difficult.
You're always going to end up voting for the candidate who's closest.
Alright,
so they're only really relevant strategy is to run or not.
It's a rock to stand on,
not to stand.
All right,
so just to make that clear,
voters vote
for the closest running candidates
first and second.
What does it mean to win?
We'll assume that we're in a plurality election here.
So the winner is the person who gets a plurality.
You win.
If you get the most votes in the woods,
you win.
If you get the most votes and want,
assume that if there's a tie that we flip a fair coin or a Supreme Court judge,
whatever you want to say.
Good bye.
All right.
Sorry.
Flip if ty.
All right.
And the payoffs in this game
as follows,
we'll assume that there's a price for winning.
So if you win the election,
you get a prize equal to B.
All right?
We'll also assume that there's a cost of running.
So if you enter this election,
win or not,
you incur a cost of C and we'll assume,
okay,
that B is greater than equal,
greater than or equal to two c and actually for today.
But today,
let's just keep things simple and assume it's actually equal to Suzy.
Ah,
but that's not the every part of the payoffs.
There's also a part of the payoff that's analogous to forcing me to drink by
blight or forcing the Pepsi drinkers to Drink Coca Cola and watch that.
That's if,
regardless of of,
uh,
of whether I run on ours,
if some other candidate is elected other than me,
then they're not going to have my ideal policies.
All right?
So it's going to cause me on happiness.
It's going to cause me dish Tennessee having a candidate win who's far away from
me.
All right?
So there's going to be a,
an extra thing.
And
so if,
if your position is x,
if you are x on that line
and the winner of the election
is at y,
then you pay a cost of minus x minus y,
the absolute distance between between you and the winning candidate.
So again,
if you're an ex and the winners,
that why it hurts you minus the distance between x and Y in terms of your own
happiness and having a winner who isn't,
who's far away from you winning.
So let's do an example.
Okay?
Just to make sure we understand the pay offs.
So example one,
if you're an x,
just called,
you missed the x,
it's kind of missed act.
Can I get glare?
So Mr [inaudible] position x,
if he enters the election and he wins the election,
then his payoff is B because he entered minus c,
sorry B,
because he one minus c cause he had to pay his lecture expense,
right?
But the winning candidate is him.
So he gets no disutility from the winning candidate being someone else.
All right,
second possible.
Let's see
if mr x enters.
But Mr,
why wins then?
X is payoff is what he's,
he's still incurred minus c cause he ran and he also has a cost of x minus y
cause he doesn't like Mr. Why winning
and
food.
Hey if mr x stays out,
but Mr why wins?
Okay
then missed x's payoff.
He doesn't,
when he doesn't get B,
he doesn't lose.
See cause he didn't run,
but he still has this disability minus x minus y cause it doesn't like why
winning?
All right.
Does everyone understand this game?
Ever understand the game.
They are not understanding the game at this point.
All right,
so in principle we could play this with the whole class,
but let's uh,
single out a particular row of the class.
So I'm going to come down here and I guess eventually while I grab it in a
minute,
all right,
so I'm going to use this row,
I think this row,
okay.
This Rogers,
everyone in this row stand up a second.
Okay.
I remember.
And this row stand up.
All right.
This is the row of potential voters.
They're the voters there also the potential candidates.
All right.
So we need,
we need to have a convention here,
whether we're,
whether we're viewing this from the perspective of people behind them or people
in front of them.
Let's view it from the perspective people in front of them.
So,
so,
uh,
I got an hour I'll cal did around.
People were in behind the head there was active.
Okay.
So this gentleman here whose name is
Andy.
Andy,
thank you.
Andy is our crazy right wing guy.
All right.
And uh,
so,
so deep tip toe tip toe is all crazy left wing guy,
right?
And everyone else is in between.
There's one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
seven,
eight,
nine,
16 people here.
Um,
uh,
let,
let me,
let me add [inaudible] make it 17 peoples.
We haven't had an odd numbers.
They've got to go and just go and sit in that row.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Just cause it's more like,
okay,
now we have 17 people at this bit.
Bit Easier.
All right?
Just want to avoid obvious ties.
Okay.
All right.
So how's this going to work?
Every sit down again.
But don't put your,
you keep your books hand,
you can go like you get,
this is gonna be pretty aerobic.
Alright,
so these are,
these are the potential voters and each of them is in the position that uh,
Fred Thompson was in two weeks ago in the Republican primary when he's deciding
whether to run or not.
All right?
But in the real world,
that's like a sequential game.
People decide to run in some order.
We're going to as soon as his,
all simultaneous.
All right?
So what we're gonna do is we're going to hold essentially this game,
right?
We're going to ask everybody in this row,
Whether they want to intern on,
let's make some real numbers.
Let's assume that B is equal to $2.
So the spoils of government are $2 and intrigue cost you $1 a c is $1.
And we'll assume that the amount of digital is that you get from being,
from being a far away from the winner is one 17th of each of these.
Each place is worth one 17 to a dollar.
All right?
On the sensor,
whatever.
Want somebody to be told over,
bro.
Roughly 5 cents,
roughly 5 cents for each position away.
Okay,
everyone understanding the frog,
what we're doing,
I'm not getting to know you guys.
You guys over here.
You understand what we're doing?
All right,
so on the count of three,
on the count of three,
anybody who's entering this election is going to stand up.
Ready?
One,
two.
Okay,
well
that's the opposite of what's happening with the Florida primary.
Yeah.
Question.
You guys have to decide whether you're okay if you're going to,
if you're running,
you stand up.
Okay.
If for standing,
you stand.
All right.
For Stanley used hand.
All right,
let's try again.
One,
two,
three.
All right.
Stay standing.
Thanks.
They anything and I'll come around a second.
All right,
so here's our,
here's our election.
Here's our election and it's between a which way to under do it.
This is all left wing candidate.
This is our moderate left wing candidate whose name is Alex,
Alex,
and are kind of center candidate.
Maybe even the centrist candidate whose name is Beatrice.
Alright.
Alright,
so this is the election.
Who's going to win this election?
Right?
Beatrice is going to win this election,
right?
But let's just check that bitterness is going to get for me to waitress is going
to get all of right wing votes,
right?
Beatrice is also going to get a one and a half of the votes in the middle.
So what?
Right,
right.
So this vote and half the person guys vote,
right?
I've forgotten your name already again.
And Alex is going to get all the left wing boots,
but there aren't enough left wing votes here,
right?
So this is so bad is going to win.
All right?
So bear just won the selection is this array and actually collaborate?
Is this an equilibrium?
How do we know it's not an equilibrium?
I'm not telling you Katie,
how do we know this is not an even wait for the Mike with the mic.
I don't know.
This is not an equilibrium because Alex,
um,
best response to her running is to not run.
Absolutely.
So Alex here,
Alex,
and got with a payoff of what Alexson dealt with.
A payoff of minus c actually more than that,
minus c minus the distance between him and Beatrice.
So that's another a $1 5 cents,
10 cents,
20 cents,
whatever it is.
Right?
And he did it on better than not Toronto.
He hadn't run,
Beatrice would still have one.
They were just build accustomed.
The 20th sense of unhappiness at Petrus winning,
but at least you saved himself the sea of running.
Everyone here.
Let's try it again.
Okay.
Same row.
Same row,
but don't hesitate so much this time,
right?
Anyway,
count of three.
You gonna just go on.
Not Everybody in this road closed their eyes.
You can't look around.
You close your eyes.
Those are eyes.
We can do all sorts of nasty things.
Now.
Close your eyes.
All right.
Most of your stolen this row.
Okay.
All right.
All right,
so ready.
so one,
two,
three.
All right.
Can Open your eyes again.
All right,
so now,
all right,
so now what happened?
We ended up with two centrist candidates.
Let's see what happened.
So we have beer tress and your name is Claire.
Elise claralise.
All right.
And clearly she's going to get heroin vote plus one or one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
seven,
eight,
eight votes.
And Bare Truss is getting one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
seven.
How they end up with a don't,
I don't know.
Number one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
seven.
It must have been an have a full walk.
Say So.
So Clara isn't going to win this election.
All right.
Cause you've got one more vote.
Now here we ended up with too centrist candidates,
which is a result pretty close to what we saw and though telling marvel,
is that right?
Is this any collaborative?
So check out,
I counted,
right?
One,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
seven,
eight,
one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
seven.
I guess I guess if you count,
right?
So clarity is turned out to win this.
I counted that.
Correct.
What is another vote hidden behind that?
I didn't see you.
I didn't,
uh,
yeah.
Okay.
So let's,
let's just try again.
One,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
seven,
eight.
I apologize.
Beatrice won this election.
All right.
Is this an equilibrium?
How do we know this isn't an equilibrium?
Cause Tony's would rather not have.
Ron is right.
All right,
let's try one small.
All right.
Down again.
Close your eyes again.
Let's,
um,
uh,
let's just,
just keep life interesting.
Let's switch to these,
to this row.
Can we switch to this row?
Okay.
All right.
So this is our road.
Now everyone understand this?
Close your computer so you can get up without destroying thousands of dollars of
technology.
All right.
This is our row and at the count of three,
we're going to see you.
It's going to run.
Okay.
Everyone understand the game?
All right.
Close your eyes.
Close Your eyes about them.
One,
two,
three.
Yeah.
All right.
So
he said,
okay.
So I told him this,
he's going to win this election.
Is that right?
All right.
Uh,
and just,
uh,
ask the question,
is this an equilibrium?
Is this an equilibrium?
Is He,
let's count.
One,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
seven,
eight,
nine,
get 10 votes.
Obviously he hit,
there were 10 including himself through 10 votes.
Here you don't count correctly.
One,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six.
Is He actually the center guy here?
There?
I don't think he used the center guy here.
All right,
so I claim if I've counted correctly that this actually isn't an equilibrium.
Right?
Who can deviate and do better here?
Yeah.
This guy stand up a second.
Whose name is John Entered?
If I've counted correctly,
it's pretend I have.
John would actually have won this election because John is actually further to
the center.
All right.
Okay,
so let's,
thanks for a second guys.
I'll,
I'll come back to something second.
All right.
Let's try and figure out how to analyze this game.
We've played it three times.
Let's try and figure out what the equilibrium look like in this game.
Right?
This game is going on more or less right now in the primaries,
I guess the entrance data entry stage of it.
It's gone there.
All right,
so first of all,
is there a nash equilibrium in which no candidates stand?
Is there a nash equilibrium in which nobody stands?
No.
How do we know that's not a Nash equilibrium?
Somebody.
Somebody,
yeah.
How do we know that's not a Nash equilibrium?
Shout it out.
Somebody who's definitely a better off by standing up,
right?
If nobody stands,
each and every possible candidate would do better individually.
So any,
any particular voter would do better standing.
They would win the election.
Is that right?
All right.
So clearly it's not an equilibrium for nobody to stand.
That's good.
Good.
We don't see that very often.
All right.
Is there a nash equilibrium in which one and only one candidate stands?
Okay.
Yeah,
so,
so yeah,
so directly in the center.
All right,
so given that we chose an odd number of an odd number of people on the row,
if exactly one candidate stands and that candidate is the center candidates,
then that's an equilibrium.
How do we know that's an equilibrium?
Somebody give me the arguments why that's an equipment so that that's a,
it's a,
it's a good,
it's infected.
Correct gas.
But how do we know that to an equilibrium?
That's the guest pot.
How do we check that to an equilibrium?
Yeah.
Curry's shout out if anybody on either side of them chose to run,
they would lose.
They would lose.
Exactly.
So if anybody on either side of them runs right,
that person would simply lose.
It.
Wouldn't make any difference to the outcome,
right?
If a person on the right stones,
let's just try it again.
We,
we figured out that,
um,
how,
how if a pitcher stands up a second,
right?
So here's our potential equilibrium with just better standing,
And if somebody's to the,
which way do we doing it?
Somebody just the rights of Petrus was to stand so matter.
If you sound a second and your name is Stacy stands,
it doesn't make any difference.
You just lose it.
It's Beatrice winds anyway.
It just costs a bare trust and money.
Right?
And conversely,
if pitchers don't understand,
and so going a second on the woman who's wandered in from the side that just
sit,
sit down a second,
say,
see if this person stands and your name is Sarah stands.
It doesn't help.
Sarah told you,
just lose this.
Is that right?
So the evening equilibrium with exactly one candidates,
the center candidates.
Now that's looking a little bit like the median voter model,
right?
It says the isn't equilibrium with only one candidate standing and that and that
candidate would be the median candidates,
right?
Just like it was in the model we saw on your homework assignment and also a,
um,
uh,
an clause.
However we're not done yet.
There could be other equilibria,
there could be other equilibrium.
All right?
So let's just try and think about whether there are other equilibria.
So for example,
suppose now just to make life a little bit more interesting,
suppose that the voters were actually two rows and just just allow me the uh,
the uh,
um,
suspension of disbelief that these roads have the same number of people in
there.
I know they don't really.
All right,
so now what I want you to think of is that every person at every political
position,
there are two voters and hence two possible candidates.
All right?
There's two people at every position.
These two people at this position,
these two people are at this position.
All right?
Everyone understand that?
Let's assume that the roads are the same even though they're not.
And let's examine the following thing.
Suppose Beatrice stands again,
sorry.
Beatrice and the gentleman in front of him.
A friend of foe whose name is robots.
Towns as well.
So it's not a second.
All right,
so now we have two candidates standing who identical politically that right into
go write that right on top of each other.
All right,
now is that an equilibrium is not an equilibrium.
Awful limit.
That looks a lot like the downs are telling model,
right?
We've got two candidates.
Exactly at the middle.
Is that an equilibrium?
Let me try the guy up here.
No,
because if someone on either side of them were to stand up,
that person on the side would win.
Good,
good.
This can't be an equilibrium because look what happens if for clearly stands a
second.
All right,
Clara lease is gonna win all of the right wing votes,
right?
Ranging from crazy to moderate,
And these guys are going to split the left wing votes,
right?
So the total sum of right wing votes is going to beat out half of the left wing
votes.
All right?
All right.
So that can't be any gray,
the exact prediction of the downs model.
Two guys right on top of each other.
It's not an equal and sit down again guys.
All right.
All right,
let's go back to one row again cause it's easy to work with.
let's try a slightly different pattern.
So suppose seeming I counted rights,
I suppose that the following candidates enter.
So,
uh,
Clara Lewis enters and I'm sorry,
I don't know your name.
Uh,
Jean Jean enters.
So let's,
let's,
let's have a look at this array.
All right.
And assume I got it right.
And Richard is actually the center.
All right.
Now is that an equilibrium?
Is that an equilibrium?
Who thinks that isn't any collaborative?
Who thinks it's not an equilibrium?
Who's waiting to see how,
how,
how other people vote?
Well,
let's check.
Let's check.
All right,
so there's three possible types of deviation here that we can't need to check.
We need to check another entrance from the outside.
Leftwing or rightwing.
We need to check.
And another entrance in the middle of the Disney one possible one that,
and there's a third kind of deviation we should check what the third type of
deviation
one of these might choose not to run.
Why don't you mind if I tried to do it?
It might choose not to run.
Let's do them in turn.
So suppose suppose that we consider a deviation in which they're gonna have
forgotten your name in which Stacy stands as well.
Stacey,
just down a second.
All right,
so is this a profitable deviation for spacey?
No,
it's not right.
It's not.
Why isn't it a profitable deviation,
Stacy?
So two reasons,
and I also have that same one,
is that she loses,
right?
She's not going to win this election by standing.
But there's a second reason why this is a really bad deviation.
Why is it,
what's the second reason?
Yes sir.
The winter's going to be farther away from her.
Good.
So by standing alone is usually not win the election,
but she actually causes the election to be one for sure,
by Jean who's further away from her.
That's not right to space is going to pick up the right wing votes.
She's going to split the crazy right wing voters going to pick up the moderate
rightwing votes.
She's going to split with,
uh,
with claralise fry.
And gene's going to have all the left wing votes extreme and moderates.
And so from Stacy's point of view,
this is a double bad.
She doesn't get to be president.
Sorry,
I end.
You end up with a,
with a left wing president,
which he didn't like.
All right,
everyone see this so clearly.
That's a little thank you.
That sort of probably deviation.
Hang on.
Wait,
wait,
wait.
You guys were guys,
and it's also not a profitable deviation for people on the,
on the left.
Hang on a second.
All right.
So I think it's probably obvious why it's not off.
It's not a good strategy for a bit for bedrest and to hear if betters enters,
she loses.
Everyone can see that the person in the middle,
if they enter here,
lose,
loses.
They're not gonna want to answer.
All right.
So the other possible deviation we have to consider is a deviation of the form
of one of these guys dropping out.
All right,
so let's consider it.
So,
so coming back to to Clara,
lease is clarity.
It's doing better in or out.
He's clearly doing better in this election or out.
Alright,
let's think it through a second.
If she stays in,
what's her payoff?
She wins be with probably a half she costs.
See for sure that's a wash,
right?
Because be over the way we work things out be with $2.
See was $1.
So be over two minus C is,
is a wash,
right?
In terms of the of,
so in terms of the benefits of the spoils of government versus the cost of
running,
it's a wash for clarity's whether she enters a note,
right?
But by entering she has a half chance of winning the election.
All right.
So when we think about is,
is the expected distance from her of the winning candidates is with probably a
half it herself.
That's nothing.
No distance.
And we'll probably a half to two places away,
right?
So an expectation.
It's one place away.
If she drops out,
gene wins for sure.
All right,
so the expected distance away from her for the winning candidate is to away.
All right?
Just to say it again.
So the cost and direct benefits of government or a wash for her,
but by dropping out,
she ensures that somebody further away from her wins.
For sure.
That's bad.
So she's going to stay in under Saint Margaret goes the other way.
So this is an equilibrium,
man.
We're not done.
And of course we're at a time.
So what are we going to do when we come back next week?
But what are you doing?
Don't pack up yet.
We're going to do,
we're going to come back to this row.
I'm going to figure out not just this equilibrium but all equal.
But before you go there,
it's just think about it a second so you can think about it and talk about it at
home.
So what we just saw was an election in which we saw two candidates,
Jean and Clara,
Elise,
who both stood very close to each other.
But a different question is,
hang on before you go,
before you go.
Stand up my very that my very left wing Guy [inaudible] way or that way there's,
Yup.
Yup,
And stand up my very right wing guy.
He's a candidate.
Here's now carbon with two entrance and it's an extreme right wing guy and
extreme left wing guy.
Is that an equilibrium?
Think about it until we come back on Monday.